[Música]
vamos ahora a dar la bienvenida a
nuestro primer invitado del día con el
que vamos a hablar de las cientos de
personas que están varadas entre la
frontera de chile y de Perú después de
que el gobierno peruano peruano haya
endurecido la política migratoria de su
país para frenar la llegada de migrantes
y expulsar a aquellos que no tengan sus
documentos en regla ahora para el
análisis conectamos con Gerardo
espíndola él es alcalde de arica
municipio de chile en la frontera con
Perú Gerardo Buenos días para ustedes
saludo desde los estudios de Franz 24 en
español en Bogotá
Hola Rosa un gusto grande Saludos desde
arica chile empiezo preguntando por Cuál
es la situación en su municipio
Sí mira bueno la situación de arica hoy
día es compleja especialmente en la
frontera no es tanto en la ciudad más y
en la zona fronteriza que es muy cercana
también a la ciudad donde tenemos un
grupo importante de personas todos los
días son cerca de doscientas personas
250 personas que están en el límite
fronterizo en su mayoría son personas
venezolanas también internacionales pero
es menor la la cantidad y ellos intentan
Ingresar a Perú están devolviendo de de
chile hacia Venezuela su destino no es
Perú su destino es Venezuela y Perú
efectivamente hace aproximadamente en
unas dos tres semanas empezó a endurecer
las medidas de ingreso a las personas
que no tienen documento algo que se
entiende perfectamente todos los países
buscan medidas de poder controlar estos
procesos migratorios Y eso ha generado
que estas personas queden varadas en
nuestra ciudad esto comenzó nosotros lo
detectamos como municipalidad en
septiembre de basado el flujo de
personas que estaban migrando saliendo
de chile por arica pero eh a raíz de la
militarización de las fronteras en Chile
especialmente
las frontera chileno peruana y la
frontera chileno boliviana para poder
ordenar la la migración Esto fue
aproximadamente hace un mes y medio
atrás tacna que es la vecina ciudad de
chile pero en Perú empezó a tener mucha
presión de personas que no podían
Ingresar a Chile cerca de ocho mil
personas y eso hizo que Perú endureciera
sus sus normativas para ingresar
finalmente a Perú y tenemos estos
conflicto que se están viendo hoy día en
la pantalla sí Y ahora continuamos con
el tema de la respuesta de las
autoridades pero le pregunto porque
estas personas venezolanas están
decidiendo de abandonar Chile
claro esta persona están decidiendo
abandonar chile esto es
hay diferentes razones por las que están
tomando esta decisión esto En parte el
año pasado segundo semestre por lo menos
nosotros lo detectamos y entre las
razones con la que hemos conversado con
la gente especialmente nos han dicho el
tema económico el país está muy caro la
inflación hay harta inestabilidad
laboral sobre todo para las personas
migrantes que no tiene sus documentos al
día y en los últimos años chile también
ha ido creciendo ciertas políticas de de
control migratorio en nuestra ciudad y
especialmente ha aumentado
en el país más que más que una política
de de gobierno la xenofobia también en
nuestro país producto de el desorden
migratorio Pero además con este desorden
migratorio tuvimos un ingreso de banda
eh criminales a nuestro país
especialmente son tráfico de personas
traficantes de personas que empezaron a
instalar en chile y han generado una
serie de de atentados o delitos más bien
dicho incluso a la policía y eso ha
generado también un ánimo negativo
migrantes en Chile creo que son parte de
las cosas que se juntan hecho que la
gente intente salir de Chile un
porcentaje más o menos considerado y
usted habla de este incremento de la
edad xenofobia en qué expresiones usted
nos puede ejemplificar en que haya
aumentado digamos esta criminalización
de los migrantes
mire tú lo puedes ver especialmente
bueno en redes sociales en comentarios
medios de comunicación Incluso en
discursos de algunos sectores políticos
o políticos mismos que son líderes de
opiniones de algunos espacios donde se
se vincula a la a la migración con la
delincuencia y también lo hemos visto
por ejemplo en las encuestas de opinión
donde un porcentaje importante de los
chilenos indican que la delincuencia es
producto o el aumento de la del aumento
de la migración y En rigor lo que
nosotros hemos tenido en nuestro país es
que este desorden migratorio dejó en
evidencia y las fronteras de chile son
bastante permeables entonces ante ante
este desorden migratorio ante la falta
de estado en los procesos de migración
de estado de Estados ni siquiera de
estado Chile sino que de los estados
aparecieron finalmente están mafias
aprovecharon la vulnera la
vulnerabilidad de nuestras fronteras
para ingresar y claro finalmente tu
mezcla todo y se generan estas
expresiones de xenofobia y que la
encuesta indican bastante bien en el
fondo que la migración tiene mucha
relación con la con la delincuencia
claro una amalgama que lamentablemente
no solo tiene lugar en los discursos en
América Latina sino en todo el mundo y
le preguntó Qué piden ustedes a las
autoridades nacionales tanto de chile
como de Perú que hagan para resolver
esta situación
bueno nosotros como municipalidad Somos
la municipalidad que está afectada
finalmente por esta situación hemos
estado pidiendo ya yo estuve en la
cancillería de chile la semana pasada y
estamos en realidad con este diálogo más
o menos desde el mes de noviembre cuando
empezamos a detectar esta situación lo
hablamos con el Ministerio del interior
y de ahí está surgiendo la idea de hacer
un corredor humanitario terrestre aéreo
como sea y en el caso de que fueron
corredor humanitario terrestre que
permita descomprimir lo que está pasando
en las fronteras es que tanto chile Perú
Ecuador Colombia y Venezuela se pongan
de acuerdo para el para el traslado
terrestre de personas hasta Venezuela
siendo Perú Ecuador y Colombia solamente
países de tránsito y no países de
destino y para eso y hay que establecer
una buena coordinación una ejecución o
financiamiento por organismos
internacionales como por ejemplo las
Naciones Unidas y el control de estos
buses caravanas como fuera de la policía
en cada país O si fuera un un tren
perdón
[Música]
un corredor humanitario aéreo también
habría que coordinarlo con las
autoridades y corresponden a Chile o
Venezuela y Gerardo muy rápidamente
porque se nos acaba el tiempo cuál han
sido Cuáles han sido los impedimentos a
que se establezca este corredor
humanitario que se pide desde hace tanto
tiempo mira en el caso en el caso del
terrestre falta la coordinación entre
los países y falta también que Venezuela
se pronuncie si efectivamente va a abrir
o no sus fronteras para el ingreso de
las personas debería hacerlo cierto eso
de todos los países están obligados a
recibir esos connacionales pero la buena
noticia es que Venezuela se está
manifestando a favor de mandar aviones a
Chile ya lo es algo que está cada vez
más maduro y avanzando con más fuerza
Ahora hay que tomarlo con cautela hay
que ver efectivamente como esto se va a
ejecutar si es que se puede ejecutar
donde se va a ejecutar En qué ciudad y
la cantidad de personas que va a poder
llevar Los criterios porque acá las
personas todos los días llegan personas
porque las personas hay un grupo
importante que logre Ingresar a Perú de
manera Regular o de manera irregular por
eso que las doscientas personas que
están acá no son no que llevan dos
semanas son todos los días van llegando
personas cerca de las doscientas
personas 150 pasan 50 quedan 150 quedan
Y tenemos todos los días un flujo
importante de personas que van llegando
por eso es que si va a ser un avión hay
que tener una coordinación muy fina para
que impacte lo menos posible en nuestra
ciudad y genere tampoco un ingreso
masivo de personas que tengan esperanza
de subirse un avión donde quizás no no
va a llegar o donde quizás hace muy
pocas personas las que se van a poder ir
bueno Gerardo Lamentablemente Nos
quedamos sin tiempo Esperamos que
finalmente se logre a una solución que
sea respetuosa con los Derechos Humanos
de las personas Muchísimas gracias por
estar con nosotros en France 24 muchas
gracias a ustedes un abrazo desde ahí y
ustedes sigan con nosotros Porque
enseguida regresamos con más alta
calidad internacional
[Música]